well good evening and welcome to a
special edition of tucker carlson
tonight i'm will kane in for tucker now
if you want to know what is in a bill in
congress and what it's actually going to
do take a good look at the name of the
bill whatever it is
you can be sure the legislation will do
the exact opposite the american recovery
and reinvestment act of 2009 for example
and led to the worst economic recovery
this country had seen since world war ii
the so-called marketplace fairness act
is just an internet sales tax which big
companies like amazon support why
because it helps amazon price out
smaller competitors and according to
congress that's marketplace fairness
so we should all be very nervous very
very concerned that congress just passed
something called
the inflation reduction act
it mandates hundreds of billions of new
dollars and spending that will increase
the money supply in this country and
that will in turn
devalue the currency and that in turn
cause more inflation that's basic supply
and demand but before we get into the
specifics of the legislation keep in
mind life is already so expensive in
this country that we literally have
bread lines in major cities fox's jeff
flock just spoke to volunteers at one
food bank in camden new jersey who say
that many people cannot afford rice and
beans
look at all these people this is a line
that runs almost around the block here
uh yeah things cost more and so people
that otherwise you know you look people
and people well dressed in line that you
know typically would not be at a food
bank but they are pre-pandemic we were
at phil abundance feeding about 90 000
people per week and now we're about 140
000 people per week rice pasta beans
we're also finding that finding those
items for us is getting to be very
expensive as well i just want to again
start the line of folks here and this is
all sorts of folks there
families single people
a lot of these people would not be in a
line
to try and get some food
that's america
and that's happening all across america
and you have to wonder why then is the
byte administration devaluing money when
we have breadlines
well their justification for the bill is
that it will stop the climate from
changing
that's why the bill includes 50 billion
dollars in subsidies for electric
vehicle purchases which by the way will
lead manufacturers to jack up the price
of electric vehicles we've learned that
lesson from health care subsidies and
subsidies for college tuition
there's also billions of dollars for the
postal service
to buy new mail trucks that don't
pollute as much and of course
there's 100 billion dollars for the
so-called renewable industry and that
includes manufacturers of solar panels
and wind turbines
so
is that a good investment let's see
right now virtually every major
renewable manufacturer is based in china
china makes 80 of the world's solar
panels in most of the world's wind
turbines so it's safe to say china
understands renewables but here's the
revealing thing
china is not relying on those renewables
for power generation
take a look at this chart it shows
annual carbon emissions from china the
us and europe going back to the 70s
notice our emissions have been going
down for years china's by contrast has
been rising dramatically
that's because they're not shutting down
their coal plants in fact they're
building more coal plants than the rest
of the world combined
what that means
is that china wants the rest of the
world to run on so-called renewables but
china doesn't want renewables for
themselves
and that's because china benefits
financially and strategically when
western countries sabotage their own
energy supply in the name of protecting
the climate but like any good dealer
they don't get high on their own supply
and most americans recognize that
take a look at this recent tweet from
rasmussen the polling outfit
people in this country care about of
course things like inflation the economy
crime immigration and by contrast most
americans recognize the media is far
more interested in pushing false
narratives about climate change and
there's good reason for that
you'll notice no one in the media ever
blames countries like china or india for
their carbon emissions even though they
are the world's largest polluters
instead
the media blames americans
it's almost a privilege to care about
inflation as your number one issue
um the same is true of gas prices or
even the idea that it's the economy
stupid i always found that analysis
lacking because as a black person i
don't want to get killed on the way to
my job
so i'm glad i have a job i'm glad i make
a living wage but if i can't be alive
then
what does that other stuff matter
that's a television host in a television
studio lecturing people standing in
breadlines about their privilege
and by the way this is how the white
house views inflation as well they're
openly mocking anyone who is concerned
about inflation how do you know that
well to illustrate the point the byte
administration just approved a three
hundred thousand dollar grant to promote
gay and transgender social acceptance
in botswana
the daily callers reporting that african
country can expect the funds anytime
soon
meanwhile americans can't afford rice
and beans
it's such an obvious failure of
leadership no one can defend this
at msnbc they've been reduced to this
if you just lost your house because of a
flood in kentucky if you just lost your
livelihood because it burnt down in a
wildfire if you just lost your life
because you are the wrong color and you
were pulled over somewhere
inflation doesn't really matter to you
or or trigger loved ones
there are much broader things going on
right now in this country that affects
so many demographics
that the dollars to sense case that that
has been made time and again about you
know like you said it's the economy
stupid uh there's a blind spot there and
you'll notice that the majority of
people who make that statement are are
generally white
inflation recession that's not really
what matters in lies
if you notice the footage we showed you
earlier about the bread lines not a
racial issue inflation hurts poor
americans the most and that happens to
cut across racial lines
so why are we really making inflation
worse if it's not to save the climate
and it's not about punishing privileged
americans what's the point
here's one clue buried in the bill is a
big giveaway to the internal revenue
service the agency stands to gain 80
billion dollars from this legislation
that will allow the agency to hire more
than 80 000 new agents
keep in mind the irs is already
wonderfully
mysteriously heavily militarized they've
stockpiled thousands of firearms and
millions of rounds of ammunition why
does the irs need all that weaponry why
do we need to make the irs
even more powerful exactly
we know the point
isn't to investigate wealthy or powerful
americans the most recent version
of the bill
keeps the carried interest loophole
intact now that benefits wealthy
individuals and institutions in
particular hedge fund managers who are
some of the democratic party's biggest
donors so
it won't be goldman sachs doors being
kicked in with irs agents with those
guns
now following all this
build back better means doing exactly
what china and hedge fund managers that
make a lot of money in china want us to
do what do americans get out of the deal
apparently a lot more inflation and
probably
a lot more audits
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight